hello there reject nation i am
here with him
to watch brooklyn nine-nine
season three episode eight today listen
the full-length watch-alongs are over at
our patreon for the super sexy rejects
if you would like to sync up with us so
it's uncut because the actual footage is
in there
it's a time code which you could just
watch that the time code you can just
watch time pass with this
and while we laugh obnoxiously in time
leave a like if you want it does
something i think leave a comment let's
let's experiment here leave a comment
instead no likes just the comments
most comments to no likes rage yeah
let's do that
um and the boys prepper yeah thanks yeah
you guys are good all right let's do it
guess who just came from the ps321
thanksgiving parade charles you actually
like charles i'm tommy gobbler these are
the davidsons
they want to know what happened to their
missing grandmother i have some deeply
tragic news for you
[Music]
oh boy
embarrassing
that'll be me it's embarrassing
that's like a john situation that's
right
stop wearing i would try to play it off
and make it seem like it was intentional
i'm gonna catch the turkey that did this
i.t says the internet is down what no
i had just clicked a link that said
balloon boy grew up hot no i will never
see those pictures balloon boy
if sharing is here before i'm back from
rikers can you make sure she's
comfortable and also um keep captain
holt away from her why she says he
reminds her of those judgmental trees
from lord of the rings
they're called ants get a life dweeb
and totally handle it i will take care
of sharon as long as she's carrying my
god child inside of her
i am her god husband she is my god wife
and i will god love her forever come on
man
don't say stuff like that i'm gonna
assume it's all of it and just make my
exude
god i'm sorry sir this year i'm more
thankful than ever to have you as my
captain and i am thankful for the low
price of gasoline and i'm thankful i
think there's been a misunderstanding
there's no time for everyone to have a
turn but i'm the only one that didn't
[Laughter]
buddy would you two be okay with staying
late tonight well i was gonna slow cook
a goose but i guess i could
normal cook her great hot i'm sorry if
this ruined your holiday i'm thankful
that you trust us with such an important
task and i am thankful to have such a
dedicated employee and i'm thankful
dismissed
thank you for you boyle i need a top
secret favor sharon has come to the
precinct and i need your help uh it
better not be pregnancy related cause
that crap is nasty the miracle of life
dress it up however you want that's some
disgusting animal kingdom nonsense
i've seen the tape pillow
blanket
copy of breastfeeders magazine which now
that i say it out loud sounds like porn
yep it is no
golly kinky terry says he gets very
awkward near sharon hmm that's one way
to put it ah sharon nice to see you you
look so big like a mighty truck oh
yeah
smooth
you're going so fast i don't have a
choice we can't let this place fill up
with perps yeah but you're gonna cramp
you kidding baby i've been cramming for
the past 20 minutes say i'm so attracted
to you right now
is terry back yet not yet but he will be
back any minute and in the meantime i
will take great care of my god child and
my god wife oh yes uh
terry did tell me that you might be
calling me that oh you guys talk about
me sharon
no
oh raymond hi
um captain i need you to sign this here
and here excuse me everyone we got to
keep this area clear if you could all
proceed in a wall-like fashion to the
briefing room
oh
don't know
sharon
is gone
gina
is also gone no
sharon is happy and captain holt has no
idea where she is damn we are good at
stashing pregnant ladies
guys
my water just broke oh damn we'll just
get you another one
[Laughter]
hey there sarge everything is totally
under control as you know her water
broke and she's had a couple of
contractions and hey sharon how are you
doing vaginally
oh yeah we had a terrible experience
when cagney and lacey were born last
time we went to the hospital they pushed
me to have a c-section didn't have
enough rooms and the anesthesiologist
was a med student who stabbed me in the
spinal cord ten times before he got it
right god that's real
yeah
call the doula copy that i will call the
doula which is a thing that i definitely
know what it is a doula is someone who
supports you emotionally and physically
and coaches you through the process oh i
see so sort of like a vaginal gandalf
craw yeah
you've got your plate full today and
this whole sharon having a baby thing is
honestly beneath you but i know a lot
about childbirth my ex-boyfriend
frederick was an ob gyn and we would
often talk about his work before he
started talking about it with
dave
oh you make her uncomfortable
i make her uncomfortable
oh no oh that's ridiculous
i should go confront her about this at
length
[Laughter]
i only want to help whatever is best for
sharing really
you're fine with that absolutely i don't
take it personally i mean it's about me
and my behavior specifically nobody else
not hitchcock or scully but
[Laughter]
god
this guy knows where our murderer's
hiding
just give me two minutes alone with him
i'll let him know what's gonna happen to
him if he doesn't cooperate
i'm gonna miss the birth of my child oh
it's a magical moment okay okay
tell you everything thank you for
letting me be part of this wonderful
experience you're a terrible person but
you're welcome
familiarize myself with a soothing
section of your birth plan and i will
now speak in a low calming barry white
voice
oh yeah just green
baby you're making me more tense yeah i
get why i'm doing a bad bad job
[Laughter]
well i'm just getting some cds from
terry's desk to help relax sharon i
don't know why you're telling me i'm not
involved you made that
very clear oh god damn buddy
do you work here i do my son was
arrested six hours ago and nobody can
tell me when he's getting out what is
going on
what oh oh no guys we have to clear some
of these people i'm trying to keep
things calm sharon and this is not
helping i don't know what to tell you
i'm already writing dangerously fast
it's smudge city here jake smudge city i
mean the problem is we only have one fax
machine that takes four minutes per page
it's logjam city jake
there's a ton of them in that storage
room where i go to take a nap what
why didn't you say something and once
again hitchcock and scully saved the day
you didn't do anything
[Laughter]
sorry for the delay but it turns out
there's an exciting reason the train in
front of us has a pregnant woman on
board and she's giving birth oh
oh
that's where the other doula must be i
was unable to get the cds however i can
sing you a very soothing tune something
like when i get that feeling i need
sexual healing oh boy
what is that
this is like territorial mother
nonstop chaos the alarm is freaking out
sharon does anyone know how to turn it
off there's an override switch in my
office above the thermostat oh great can
you turn it off yes i'd love to help out
perhaps you'd like me to wear a bomb
suit with an opaque visor so sharon
doesn't know that it is i
i just need to flick this switch and
turn off the old alarm aruno that must
have been the wrong switch but
yep
turns on the sprinklers
and apparently does not turn them back
off
[Laughter]
excuse me everyone everyone i'm gonna
need you all to clear the room this
woman is having vaginal contractions
it's just contractions you don't have to
add
[Laughter]
where is
jerry
i don't know his phone's going straight
to voicemail maybe we should go to the
hospital no hospital yeah
no hospital
[Laughter]
oh god
i need your help
i knew this moment would come and i will
be the bigger man i'd be happy to help
great we need a doctor here immediately
we have to get your ex-boyfriend i will
not help
[Music]
oh why not dish sir dish gina no i can't
believe i'm saying this but we simply
don't have time to hear about the
captain's sorted romantic past what have
you become a hero in a time of crisis
we're going to get frederick right now
i'm sure he's over whatever little fight
you guys had
oh yes
[Music]
look
oh hell yeah
commandeer
how did you get things done before the
internet and faxing cocaine
right and also the tubes there's 27
miles of pneumatic tubes under the city
connecting all the precincts guys whoa
you really think these still work
oh i think they still
oh geez
years ago when we moved in together an
antique duck decoy of his was misplaced
it wasn't misplaced you threw it in the
trash
and with it our relationship
sharon needs a doctor so get over
yourself and tell him you threw away his
stupid duck and gave him 20 bucks to buy
a new one it cost 740
what that is an insane price for a duck
that's way too much
fredrik the duck was ugly and gross and
i threw it in the garbage wow well i
know what i'm thankful for this
thanksgiving the truth
my phone's ringing oh oh no no
terry why am i the only one who cares
about this baby
hey what took so long is she okay uh
yeah i was just telling her the entire
duck story now that it finally has a
satisfying ending
we're surrounded by criminals there's no
bed and you can hear the faint sound of
someone screaming through all the vents
that's hitchcock his arm's stuck in a
pneumatic tube it's hilarious
[Laughter]
i don't want to risk anything by making
a stupid mistake
look you're my god husband we both know
that's a fake position not anymore
what would you do
rip that baby out
i tried calling you you didn't pick up
so you decided to do the exact opposite
of the one thing i told you i thought it
was the right thing to do terry look
she's in there with captain holt's
ex-boyfriend right now but don't worry i
made him promise to stop bringing up the
duck what the hell
i didn't throw the duck in the garbage i
threw it off a bridge
he knew i disliked the duck because of
its weak beak but he insisted on
displaying it anyway
this is agonizing it's been over an hour
this has to be a record for longest
childbirth
it's a girl yay
charles and amy filling out forms i'm
rosa i'm so thankful you got me here on
that bike i am thankful i could help i'm
thankful that i'm well this is clearly a
moment between him and diaz
sharon and i wanted you to be the first
person to meet oh
that's so nice
godfather
i'm sorry i got angry earlier you did a
great job
hospital was the right decision
i'm so glad you're ava's godfather
so glad you're sharon's got husband
i'm so glad you're my god wife
you wanna hold it
oh um
yeah sure that'd be crazy
[Music]
how heartwarming
oh sweet
that was sweet
very sweet
and we're back
yeah that was uh
a beautiful touching episode in the end
of it all
um not gonna lie to you guys kind of had
a tough phone call that just came in
it's sort of affecting me slightly but
i'm gonna just come back to
ground level with you all right it's fun
i'm gonna try to just you know like
ignore it but no i if it looked like a
different mood than how it was when i
was reacting
unfortunately it's life life just
sometimes intervenes and [ __ ] happens
um but yeah as this episode was going i
i this is the kind of episodes that i
admire the most i like a cacophony of
catastrophe as it all piles on to one
another like that level of escalation
and i wasn't expecting such a
heartwarming uh like truly touching
the conclusion in the end where terry's
just gathered around and thanking
everyone
for who they are as people you know and
the the sacrifices they made and the
internal challenges they overcame in
order to help make that day happen i
thought was so beautiful
and i also like the the the the nuanced
heart was not something i saw coming
especially with like jake because
there's all those jokes about him
wanting to be the godfather
and wanting to be a god dad like the god
husband and all these things god wife i
thought like they're they're funny
they're funny little jokes
um
but
i loved i loved coming to the conclusion
of oh we're really seeing him earn his
way to that title and i i just did not
see that happening before me
and i think that makes it even more
powerful where he doesn't even realize
that's what he's doing
like it's not like they put him to the
challenge to the test
of it of like the today's day you proved
this jake it's just
because of the unforeseen challenges
that that came his way and how much he
put in that effort
uh
and then like to have that look on his
face when he says like you're going to
be a great godfather or whatever
whatever terry says to him that i
thought was so
beautiful
because even he didn't realize like he
proved himself today
and he wasn't even setting out it wasn't
even like the setup was to prove himself
that wasn't even the setup of jake's
story for this episode
but
that makes it even stronger because it
just shows us who he is as a as a person
that he will be there not just to
fulfill some sort of recognition or ego
but for the betterment of
terry's wife what's her name what's her
name
sharon is it sharon sharon
sheila no not sheila might be sure i
think sharon
um
yeah so
that was that was really that was really
touching it was really touching i
thought really well written and i liked
when you you don't you don't see exactly
what it is that the show is showing you
yeah yeah where it like sneaks up on you
this had a nice nuance for that because
yeah we've had i feel like whenever they
go into one of these episodes that has a
more heartwarming or a more sort of
personal conclusion they do kind of
nicely transcend
uh some of the more neat and tidy
aspects of like comedy writing i would
imagine because this episode like it has
tons of hijinks and jokes and random
circumstances and you know you get your
fun cameo like there's so many things
going on that a typical episode would
have and a certain level of chaos
befitting of any of these but there's
something really cool to me about this
one watching jake in the center of it
all because as much as they play up
always how immature he is and how kind
of uh you know his uh offbeat sense of
humor can get him into trouble i
appreciated that this episode really was
sort of about him in the center of
everything just doing his best to do a
pretty good job and yeah there are
certain jakeisms that uh break into that
storyline there are certain punchline
gags or whatever but for the most part
this isn't yeah an episode where it's
like here's the setup you gotta prove
yourself and now we're gonna watch a
million things go wrong it's more like
he is just trying to keep it all
together and do a solid by
you know
a family that he seems to very much care
about like i like the whole god uh of
you know god father god husband all that
stuff because it really is like a
heartfelt like no no he does take this
seriously it's not just some kind of fun
gag from the past or some cool title
like he does want to do as good of a job
as possible and he gets gina to go out
of her comfort zone and he gets holt to
go out of his comfort zone other people
have to confront and clear things as he
is sort of proving himself alongside so
yeah i thought this was like a really
nicely done character episode uh that
you know didn't skimp on any of the
hilarity i loved the whole
back and forth between uh
frederick or whatever nick offerman's
name was and holt about the duck
and everything and uh i'm excited to see
him return because obviously i feel like
you get a guest star like that to have
them recur once in a while
and the way they they built up all that
stuff like there was you know it's a
thanksgiving episode that's a thing we
do every season and i thought that while
this didn't really focus that much on
the holiday sands the cold open it
really did bring it around to an episode
that feels fitting to watch
for that time of year and that kind of
vibe so uh yeah
quality episode gracefully done well
they're cops that are pretty saints in
brooklyn that are
having to work on thanksgiving you know
so i i thought like not doing like the
thanksgiving dinner hijinks
was appropriate and just bringing it
back to being grateful i thought was
really really sweet really touching
stuff yeah and yeah holt's little
bit about
not
about being petty yeah without
just acknowledging that you are
very much vexed by this situation
you are bothered you do feel
unappreciated i love that that note they
i like what they developed that note
into past the first season especially
yeah it was great it was great it was a
great one really love this one quality
um guys
leave your thoughts down below what are
you grateful for right now in this very
moment
subscribe click that bell last but not
least let's do a page
jean jeter my favorite new york cop on
the beat i'm thankful for you buddy
you've been one of our longest and most
enduring supporters out here plus i love
the things that you send our way i don't
always understand
but i do always appreciate i hope that
you one day will agree to be my god wife
or god husband whatever you want to call
yourself but if i ever have a wee lad or
lass or anything in between you will be
the one i call in a crisis to come help
out to come look after the child if i
should die who's going to look after the
kid jean jean's going to raise that kid
to be the coolest most creative
strangest photographer in all of the
land so buddy i hope you're doing well
hope you're staying safe and we'll catch
you next month
with more thanks and gratitude for you
being you eugene love you buddy
[Music]
you